I mean ultimately he will withdraw is he
gonna stick this one out I see no
prospect of his withdrawing that's not
his psychology and sort of what would he
do if he quit it would be such
self-immolation and he's not someone who
says I'm sorry very often or has guilts
or sort of recognizes when he's made a
mistake he just motors through and I
think that's his only real option well
set up the debate for us then I mean is
he going to come out with all guns
blazing and we've already heard him say
after the first debate he he regrets not
raising some of Bill Clinton's actions
while he was in the White House and his
allegation that Hillary Clinton was as
he says an enabler do you think you'll
follow that tack to defend himself I
think there's every likelihood that he
has to do that almost at when he's
punched he always punches back that's
just the way he does things he spent
time last week tweeting at five in the
morning about the former Miss Universe
candidate that he had called fat and
Miss Piggy and when he brought it up he
just couldn't resist so now he's been
accused about his sex life in his
statement yesterday he accused her of
being an enabler and a terrible person
because of her husband so what else can
he do I mean he's gonna say I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry over and over again
he likes to punch and I think that's
what he has to do to please his crowd so
let's broaden it out bit by bit the
Republican Party I mean even when he got
the nomination huge sections the
Republicans the Grand Old Party were
shocked to say the least I mean we're
hearing them that senior figures that I
suppose the very bull works the pillars
of the Republican Party refusing to
support him but what difference does
that make to him I mean he's not a
regular Republican and where can they go
there they have no mechanism for
removing him from the ticket even if
they wanted to he essentially has to
quit himself and even if he quit getting
a new candidate in the mix with all the
states are already starting to vote
you'd have to get a new candidate on by
state-by-state festoon of lawyers would
be involved all over the place because
it would be so unusual so all they're
doing now is essentially saying whoops
we really made a mistake here please
don't take us down with you
and that's why we're having I think so
many people who really don't like him
and have loathed him to some degree for
a long time but figured it was too
dangerous for them as Republicans to
alienate his base saying oops I just
can't go any further and I've got to
figure out some way to distance myself
and hope hope that I'm not brought down
in this tidal wave and on the morality
basics I mean look at that so-called
Bible Belt supporters of the Republicans
how's this playing with them well it's
interesting the mountain west the Mormon
communities they're the been the fastest
in a way and been the most determined to
be offended by him a lot of Bible Belt
people do find him offensive but they
will say I find Hillary Clinton's
possible presidency more offensive and
I'll just hold my nose I mean there is
an awful lot of I think tension and
anxiety and the Democrats hope is that a
lot of Republicans just don't show up
because they can't bear to vote for him
and if that happens then they do have a
prospect of perhaps doing well in the
Senate races and the house races which
would be there of course greatest hope
of all okay the consolation prize but I
mean it see one more terrible leak away
from having to give up we think about
that there were those tax returns from
the 90s than this has he got another
chance well we have a debate tonight but
he might do better expectations are
certainly low and Hillary could stumble
I mean it's already still have a month
to go and we hardly even remember the
tax returns which was just a week ago so
I can't say that he's got her for sure
but it does not look good for him okay
Jeff thanks very much indeed